today on the matt well show michelle
obama comes out against trump apparently
she doesn't like the guy
who who would have thought calling him
racist a liar immoral but speaking of
liars she lies repeatedly in her attack
we'll get to the truth today also joe
biden makes empty calls for unity but
i'll explain why unity in america
is impossible and in our five headlines
hollywood
plans a film lionizing katie hill the
congresswoman who sexually took
advantage of her subordinates
me too was already dead but it's
especially dead now
and our daily cancellation i will cancel
all drivers on the road
except for me all other drivers are
canceled i'll i'll explain why
all of that on the way but first a word
from lifelock you know
there's no need to be paranoid but it's
not paranoia to say that there are a lot
of
identity thieves out there in cyberspace
and they'd all like to have a piece of
you
of your identities specifically if they
can that's why you need to protect
yourself with lifelock
what's called synthetic identity fraud
is is one one of the fastest growing
financial crimes
in the us it happens when criminals use
a combination of fake and real
information
to create an entirely new identity they
combine
real personally identifiable information
such as
social security number with a fake name
an address to open bank accounts
seek credit or even obtain health
insurance it's very devious stuff and
it's hard to catch on your own
if you're just monitoring your credit
that's not going to be enough you could
miss
certain threats if that's all you're
doing good thing
there's a life flock light flock detects
a wide range of identity threats like
your social security number being for
sale in the dark web
other threats as well no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can find out if your information
is on the dark web get your free dark
web scan at lifelock.com
scan pick the plan that's right for you
save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
walsh that's a free scan at lifelock.com
and 25
off with promo code walsh all right so
michelle obama who
i'm repeatedly reminded is charismatic
and deeply likable
though i've yet to find any evidence at
all for this claim released a video on
behalf of the biden campaign
where she lays into donald trump calls
him a
racist liar but in the process of
calling trump a liar she herself
lies with impunity especially when it
comes to defending the violent
marxist radicals of blm here's some of
that
portion of what she said listen they're
stoking
fears about black and brown americans
lying about how minorities
will destroy the suburbs whipping up
violence and intimidation
and they're pinning it all on what's
been an
overwhelmingly peaceful movement for
racial solidarity
it's true research backs it up only a
tiny fraction
of demonstrations have had any violence
at all
so what the president is doing is once
again
patently false it's morally wrong
and yes it is racist
but that doesn't mean it won't work
because this is a difficult time a
confusing time
and when people hear these lies and
crazy conspiracies
repeated over and over and over again
they
don't know what to think with everything
going on in their lives
they don't have time to fact check
falsehoods
being spread throughout the internet and
even
reasonable people might get scared
and the one thing this president is
really really good at
is using fear and confusion and
spreading lies
to win patently false morally wrong
and racist that's how michelle obama
describes donald trump
but she may as well have been speaking
into a mirror instead of the camera
because
her words apply much more to herself
she says that the protests quote unquote
have been overwhelmingly peaceful
and that only a tiny fraction have had
any violence at all
how does she know this well research she
says research
backs it up i i love it when people cite
research
not actual research but just the word
research search
like what's your evidence for that that
claim you just made oh research
yeah the research all the researches oh
oh and evidence too
research and evidence that's that's how
i know just that's it research and
evidence
now she doesn't of course go into
specifics so i could only assume
that the research she's talking about is
the much ballyhooed study from the armed
conflict location
and event data project this uh which
which did a study about this summer's
protest
and its findings were trumpeted by the
mainstream media with headlines like
this one from the guardian saying
nearly all black lives matter protests
are peaceful
despite trump narrative report fines
and what did this study actually find
well it says according to the guardian
the vast majority of the thousands of
black lives matter protests this summer
have been peaceful
with more than 93 percent involving no
serious harm to people or damage to
property
now already there's a a problem with the
serious harm qualifier
what counts as serious harm and why
shouldn't the supposed
non-serious harm still be included as
violent
i mean if you punch me in the face and
barely manage to give me a nosebleed
does that mean that your punch wasn't
violent or does it just mean that you
have scrawny toothpick
arms and you punch like a child now
in any case let's just go with this
research for a moment for the sake of
argument
and say okay seven percent it also says
that between may and august
there were seven thousand seven hundred
and fifty blm demonstrations now what's
seven percent of seven thousand seven
hundred fifty i'll let you do the math
mainly because i'm too stupid to do it
but i do know that it's several hundred
so by these very favorable calculations
trying to put things in the most
positive possible light for blm
still we are left with the conclusion
that there were several hundred
violent blm demonstrations that involved
serious harm to people property or both
in the span of one summer this according
to michelle is a tiny fraction
i wonder would she still consider
several hundred violent demonstrations
in the span of just three months
a tiny fraction if these were maga
rallies descending so frequently into
looting an arson
would seven percent be a tiny fraction
of say pro-life rallies that involve
torching abortion clinics would seven
percent be a tiny fraction of
fecal coated chocolate chips in a
chocolate chip cookie
i'm just trying to figure out when seven
percent becomes tiny is it only for blm
violence
i'm pretty sure that if that if i were
to say only a tiny fraction of people
who've contracted covid have died from
it
michelle will take issue with that even
though the fraction is far
far far less than seven percent
yes it would seem that seven percent
becomes tiny only in a very selective
and politically useful
circumstance so michelle obama or anyone
else on the left
um mob violence as somehow peaceful
what she and they really mean to say is
that in their minds
the violence doesn't matter or perhaps
is even justified
this is something to to keep in mind
when you listen to another message from
the biden campaign also from yesterday
this is from joe biden himself
who went to gettysburg in a bit of a
self-aggrandizing stunt
to give a message on unity and here's
what some of that sounded like if for
some reason you want to hear it listen
here on this sacred ground
abraham lincoln reimagined america
itself
here a president of the united states
spoke of the price of division
and the meaning of sacrifice he believed
in the rescue redemption and
rededication of the union
all this in a time not just
a ferocious division but of widespread
death
structural inequity and fear
of the future and he taught us this
a house divided could not stand
that is a great and timeless truth
today once again we are a house divided
but that my friends can no longer be
we are facing too many crises we have
too much work to do
we have too brighter future to have a
shipwrecked
on the shoals of anger and hate
and division yes unity we must have
unity not hate
not anger and division but remember that
for the democrats
rampaging through the streets looting
throwing a molotov cocktail at a cop
none of that counts as anger and
division for them
unity and peace may include burning down
the local cvs
and this is precisely why all of the
happy talk about
unity the speechifying the empty
gestures towards it
all of that is meaningless and can never
bring about true unity
because as i've argued in the past we
are as a nation divided on such a
fundamental
and foundational level all the way down
at the roots of our being
that unity is simply not possible to
unite we have to unite around something
in something for something buy something
because of something
unity for unity's sake can only ever be
shallow it can't be lastic it can't be
real
but we live in different universes now
as americans not even two different
universes this is like a multiverse
situation everyone has their own
we are unmoored from reality and truth
and biden and the democrats they want us
to unite
in their universe a universe where blm
radicals torching a police station are
peaceful
and where babies aren't people and where
men are women and where college
graduates have a god-given human right
to have their debts paid off
by appropriating funds from those more
successful than them or even less
successful
and so on all of their calls for unity
should include that disclaimer yes
come unify with us in our universe
in our reality and that
i simply cannot do it's not even that i
won't do it it's that i can't
i also won't but i can't so where do we
go from here
where does that lead us well i don't
know exactly
but the happy talk isn't gonna help us
and certainly the lies from michelle
obama and others
won't either let's get to our five
[Music]
headlines
well they told us uh 15 days to slow the
spread
15 days turns out speaking of words not
meaning anything well turns out 15 days
means more like seven months and
counting it's been seven months
since the nation locked down because of
covet 19
and many businesses are still feeling
those effects of the lockdowns in
in very difficult ways and if you're a
business owner you know that much better
than i do
so if you're looking to get some
business insight right now and a lot of
a lot of people are
register for expert ownership live a
virtual conference october 21st and 22nd
featuring world-renowned leaders like
john maxwell
um the founders of uh duck commander and
otterbox
the benham brothers and our personal
favorite the daily wire god king jeremy
borg
also is going to be there the two-day
virtual conference will set up set you
up with skills that you need to
to get you through this crisis you can't
miss this you'll hear stories about the
challenges of startup journeys
and the tough times that come with you
know any company and how these
individuals push through failure
to come out success successful i can't
even successfully say the word
successful that's how unsuccessful i am
uh came out successful on the other side
this is a pretty incredible lineup and
we'd love
to have you join today for 147
go to expertownershiplive.comwalls to
register with an opportunity to buy a
second ticket for a friend
50 off invest in yourself invest in your
business
and you know come on you don't want to
miss this you don't want to miss jeremy
the god king he's going to be there
visit expert ownership live dot com
walsh for 147 today that's expert
ownership
live.com
walsh okay
so we start here all right
number one the perceptive among us
you know uh really from the beginning
knew that the me too movement was a
fraud
it was ideological it was anti-male
while masquerading as an ethical
movement which it never was
now if you need more evidence of this
even after all these years
then i would point you to katie hill
disgraced former congresswoman
who had a special announcement yesterday
she says
i can finally announce another exciting
project i'm so honored to be played by
the
the iconic elizabeth moss and thrilled
to work with this incredible team
guess i'm about to add movie producer to
my resume and there's a link to an
article about this
this movie it's a movie about katie hill
lionizing katie hill
with feminist favorite elizabeth moss in
the lead
i think she's the one she does
handmaid's tale right isn't she in that
i have no idea but that's that's why
that's probably why the feminists like
her
meanwhile um katie hill resigned from
congress if you recall following a
scandal in which it was revealed that
she was
sexually taking advantage of her staff
members
she had involved one of them in a
threesome with her then husband
and there were other major ethical
problems as well remember
we have been told by me too
that power dynamics make it so that even
consensual relationships
often times are not really consensual
okay yes doesn't always mean yes this is
what we've been told
the power dynamics between a congress
member and a staffer
make it so that consent is not fully
possible
this isn't my argument okay this isn't
what i'm saying
it it this is the metoo argument this is
what they say
and according to that argument katie
hill is a predator according to them
if they were to apply their logic
consistently which of course they don't
now you don't have to take it from me
though an apparent former staff member
uh commandeered hill's congressional
twitter account
which has just been sitting there you
know after she left
or resigned a disgrace she had her
twitter account which doesn't have
access to anymore
and this morning there were some tweets
coming out
on that account blasting the movie
saying that hill took advantage of her
subordinance caused them harm you know
this is what the two would say
hill now claims that the account was
hacked but there's no reason to think it
was hacked
her staff would have had access to that
account and it
looks like they're using it or at least
one of them is using it to say
hey you know she was a pretty horrible
boss and she took advantage of her staff
maybe don't make a movie about her where
she's the hero
but hill gets her own rules you know she
doesn't have to play by the same rules
as everybody else
um you want to talk about privilege here
it is
she's the protagonist in a film about
her own sex scandal you think any
disgraced republican politician would
ever get that treatment
exact same circumstances okay would that
ever happen
no of course not number two now um
it's long been my contention that bill
de blasio
is of new york is is not only the worst
mayor in history but also possibly
the cringiest dork in history too i
think he might he might get that title
as well
if you don't believe me then watch this
[Music]
me
yes that was uh de blasio heroically
in slow motion with the music playing
putting a mask on his face
they took a video of that puts the mask
on then offers an awkward
salute as well i don't know who the
salute is to but he does and then he
walks back and it's like
look wear the damn mask if you want okay
but stop trying to make it into a heroic
manly act on your part
biden is doing the same thing here's a
video from the biden campaign yesterday
uh so so you see him there supposed to
be con contrasting
him with with trump and you see him
putting on the mask like a champ while
trump takes his off
how heroic this is what it takes to be a
hero now
just put a mask on it's that easy
which is great uh i mean i i guess i
should be i'm a hero too
every time i you know walk into a
grocery store and i have to put the mask
on cause i'm forced to
actually it's a heroic act i'm a hero
all right number three um meanwhile
speaking of dumb theatrics
with the vp debate coming up uh there's
been this back and forth between
the camps biden trump camp over putting
a plexiglas
divider between the candidates on stage
now pence initially balked at this idea
but has now
agreed has relented and uh you could see
them putting up the the divider there
what does this achieve they're 12 feet
apart
they both they both tested negative
for the virus what does the glass
divider achieve
well nothing i mean if one of them
could manage to infect the other despite
being negative and asymptomatic and
being 12 feet apart
if they could somehow pull off that
trick then the glass barrier probably
won't do much anyway
so there doesn't seem to be a lot of
much of a point here at least medically
or scientifically um
but of course we know that that the real
reason it's there is for two reasons
number one
the biting campaign wants it there
because it gives the impression
that pence is sick and weak and infected
it's bad optics for him so that's what
that's all this is about
it's just to remind the public as
they're watching the debate oh yeah
that's the sick guy over there
even though he's not and that's what
this is really about but also number two
it's it's part of the coveted theater
that we've seen all across the country
for months
where measures are taken things are done
often with no apparent scientific
justification or reason with no ration
no rationale behind them really but the
idea
is that at least if we're doing
something it's better than nothing
even if the something is totally
arbitrary and ineffectual
and we've been in that kind of culture
for a long time it's not just with coven
we've been in this culture where you
know there's there's a there's a bad
thing that happens or there's something
we have to deal with
and the cry comes out from the public
saying do something just
somebody do something i don't care just
anything
um you get this anytime there's a uh you
know
mass shooting and you have many
americans who say to the government the
federal government just just just do
something just anything just do
something
and they go and they pass a law is the
law gonna help is it going to actually
achieve anything does it get to the core
of the problem no but it's something and
so we should be satisfied with that
getting a lot with that with a lot of
that with covet as well and it's
ridiculous and not actually helpful okay
number two
so this is a story that i've largely
ignored and
for uh for good reason i think that's
the story of
claudia conway the daughter of kellyanne
conway and george conway
she's been on social media mostly on
tick tock it seems embarrassing her
mother
spilling secrets things she thinks she
claims our secrets anyway this is a 15
year old girl we're talking about here
um and uh you know sometimes recording
her mother without permission and
posting it online
again the girl is 15 years old and the
leftist media they love it
as you'd expect because they have the
ethical sensibility of a tarantula so
for them this is great they see no
problem with it
in fact you can see in the headlines a
few headlines here we're told that the
15 year old
claudia conway is the whistleblower of
our time
now the way they're taking advantage of
this girl is obviously sick and
the sexual undertones of some of this
stuff from the left is even sicker
i mean look at this from neil brennan
who's a comedian apparently on netflix
no surprise there
and he says that claudia should make an
only fan's account
for white house intel only fans
talking about a 15 year old so that's
all disturbing and gross but
i keep going back when i see these
stories
you know i keep going back personally um
to the question of why
this girl has a phone with the internet
in the first place
if this were my daughter and i
understand the family dynamics here are
in far be it for me to dispense
parenting advice okay but and the family
dynamics are very strange
at least from the outside i mean there's
in there there are complicated family
dynamics of any family
right but uh still i i mean if this were
my daughter i would
i would i would take her phone which i
am paying for
i paid for the phone i'm paying for the
the service i'm paying for everything
so it's my pr it's my property it's not
hers
and i would take my property
and uh i would bring it out into the
into the uh garage and i would grab a
hammer and i would smash it with a
hammer and then i would throw the pieces
in the garbage can
that's what i would do
so i'm not sure why she's allowed to
continue having a phone
but then again look this is coming from
from me and uh i'm someone who
i can't really see any reason why any 15
year old
person should have a phone with the
internet
on it there's really nothing good that
can come of it
period there is there is no net positive
to your child even at the age of 15
having a phone with the internet nothing
good
so all you can hope is that the damage
it does which you know it will do won't
be
that bad so at that point it's all about
damage you give them the phone
which you have paid for and you've
purchased it with your own money
and you hand it to them this thing that
you know is gonna do damage and now
all you're doing is damage control
what about just not giving them the
phone
if your kid gets to an age or they
actually have a job and they can go out
and buy
the phone themselves you know maybe
that's a good cut off age for when they
can have if
you can buy it with your money even then
i mean if they're living in under your
house it's your rules and if you tell
them they can't have even if it's their
money it's it's still your house you can
have the rules you want but
i could see an argument there if it's
their if it's if it's
their money and they're earning and
that's what they want to spend it on
then there could be a good lesson there
but
when it's not even their money and
you're paying for it and buying it going
out of your way spending
all this money on these expensive
gadgets that you know will hurt them
uh i just i don't see it i don't know i
i don't see the parenting strategy i
really don't
number five um finally
they got him folks this is it they
finally got him
they have proven that donald trump is
actually
as suspected literally hitler
literally okay matt denzeko
um a self-described journalist and
filmmaker he has uh
on twitter taken the video that trump
released
of of him returning from the hospital
and he's juxtaposed it next to
the triumph of the will which is a nazi
propaganda film from the 30s
and what he found is stunning okay just
watch this you can see it here
and um if you're listening to the audio
podcast what we're seeing here is is it
is it matches up exactly
the two videos match up exactly shot for
shot
you can see it right down the line
stunning apparently the trump campaign
decided to do a shot for shot remake of
a nazi propaganda film
because why not well i can think of many
reasons why not actually
and i can't think of any reasons to do
that even if you are
secret nazis why would you do that
the whole point of being a secret nazi
is that you don't let people know so
that doesn't make a lot of sense
although it starts to make sense it
becomes less confusing when you realize
that oh no wait
they didn't do that at all this is total
nonsense it has over
20 000 retweets on twitter of course but
it's total absolute nonsense what uh dan
zico actually did
is he took a two-hour nazi film
and he searched for shots that resembled
the trump video
and all the trump video the trump video
is just simply helicopter lands
trump walks out and then he's on a
balcony that's it that's all the video
is
now if the video lined up that perfectly
like if if the triumph of the will was
also just a two-minute video and
the shots lined up that perfectly then
even i would admit well it's probably
you know that's probably still a
coincidence but it's a hell of a
coincidence
except in this case no they took a
two-hour movie or this guy took a
two-hour movie
and search through cherry-picking the
same sorts of shots and then just
line them up edit it stitched it
together to make
he basically he made his own nazi
propaganda film this isn't
that what you just saw there that's not
trying for the world that's that's matt
danziko's nazi propaganda film that he
created
after the fact he he created it based on
the trump video
and then said wow these things really
line up who would have thought
how did that happen well i know how it
happened i did it myself
now the problem of course is that you
could do that with any political ad okay
you could take any political ad probably
and
you could find in it probably a few
shots at least that resemble
some nazi propaganda oh look they're
both waving go to balcony
you know what else you know what else
you could do you could search through
mineconf
i bet to find the same words you could
find
i bet you there are words in mineconf
um that are also in other books in fact
i have i have my my copy of minecomp
right here
and um you know i could you know i could
even just looking through it like for
example
i the word of the word
the both in mine comp
my god think about this
of and the the and of
where do those words sound familiar
the art of the deal the trump book
wow the trump book is essentially mine
comp
incredible um anyway by the way this is
not really minecon
just so you know media matters uh this
is not really mind comp this is bill
bryson a short
history of nearly everything i don't
mean to impugn bill bryson in this way
this is actually a great book and it's
got nothing to do just to clarify it's
got nothing to do with nazi
nazis or hitler or anything like that
okay um
all right let's uh so that's it we're
gonna get to our daily cancellation in
just a second
but before we do you know
i want to tell you about rad power bikes
uh rad power bikes
the thing is it's more important than
ever to get outside enjoy the outdoors
get some fresh air
um and and this is a great way to do
that a rad power bike
you ever wonder what's so exciting about
an electric bike why people have them
well
now you can find out try it for yourself
rad power bikes were voted best
affordable electric bike in five
categories by electric bike review
but even better they're half the price
of most e-bikes i think the thing that
stops a lot of people from trying them
is just that they're so expensive but
now you can you can try it and they're
very affordable it's a great way to get
outdoors without getting hot and sweaty
uh it's a lot of fun so it's there you
got the practicality of it where you're
getting around town
but also on top of that it's just it's
a lot of fun as well it's a cross
between a traditional bike and a moped
but it doesn't require a special
driver's license like a moped would so
there's no red tape here
go up to 20 miles per hour without
pedaling and you can you know you can
you can get where you want to go
without getting all sweaty rad power
bikes are affordable most e-bikes are in
the 3 000
range rad power bikes start at just 9.99
and most are under 1500 so most of them
are
under half the price of of of other
e-bikes and some of them are even less
than that
makes the perfect gift gift for someone
as well you know someone that you really
love and you want to give them i mean
for me
i'm keeping it for myself but uh if
you're more generous than me you could
buy it for someone else
rad power bikes offer flexible financing
for as low as zero percent
apr and now for a limited time you get a
free accessory valued at up to a hundred
dollars with the purchase of a bike
that's right a free gift of up to a
hundred dollars
in value with your purchase and free
shipping for the lower 48 states so
get this special offer text the word
bike to 64
000 that's bike to 64 000 text bike
bike to 64 000.
all right and also i should mention
another another quick programming note
that tonight
make sure to tune in to all access i
will be um
i will be what's the phrase i'm supposed
to use
live reacting to the uh to the vp debate
tonight with the
which will be a very maybe i'll do it in
front of plexiglas myself to make sure
that nobody gets gets infected
while watching but tune in tonight at 8
45
pm uh eastern 5 45 p.m
pacific time and uh we'll we'll have fun
doing that okay let's get to our
daily cancellation today for our daily
cancellation i will be canceling drivers
all drivers in america except for me i'm
the only driver who is not canceled
because i'm the only good one
all other drivers are canceled you are
all no longer allowed on the roadways
so i expect smooth sailing for myself on
the highways from here on out
as the only person in the country who
knows how to drive now
i have long suspected that i am the only
good driver i've known it from before i
even had a license my dad
took me out to give me driving lessons
when i was 16. by the end of the first
drive
i was giving him the lessons that's not
entirely true i guess i i think after my
first lesson he was yelling at me that
if i don't learn to stop at stop signs
i'm going to hit someone and kill them
and he's not going to bail me out of
jail um but anyway
the point is very quickly over time i
became the only good driver
now it's well known that every man
believes that he is the only good driver
my dad believed it about himself and his
dad about himself
and you if you're a man listening
probably thinking about yourself but
it's not you i assure you it is me
which is an honor and a point of pride
but also a burden
because i have to constantly deal with
the awful driving of everybody else
this has especially been the case over
the last two weeks when i've done a
significant amount of long-distance
driving
uh hither and yan here you know there
and back and everything else and
i'll be continuing that by the way um
i'll be uh i'm driving up to grove city
for my speech after the show today
grove city college on thursday i'll be
speaking for yaf there so
make sure to make sure you you come and
tune in to that
but my recent my recent driving has only
affirmed and confirmed that everyone
is bad at driving except for me now
let's go through a list of the types of
drivers who are
especially canceled you'll certainly
find yourself on this list somewhere
there are the obvious villains you know
the drivers who drive too slow in the
passing lane or
pass in the right lane the drivers who
don't use their turn signals the drivers
who turn their turn signals on
far too early or far too late drivers
who drive under the speed limit
on one lane roads and let the cars pile
up behind them
going on like that for miles while the
people in the cars trailing behind stew
with rage and
begin engaging in violent and
unspeakable fantasies
drivers who take too long to start
driving again when the light turns green
and also drivers who start honking
immediately when the light turns green
and don't even give you a damn second to
move your foot from the brake to the gas
pedal
drivers who who speed like psychopaths
in residential neighborhoods
drivers who use their high beams when
there are other cars directly in front
of them
or driving past them in the opposite
lane drivers who slam on their brakes
when they see a cop in a speed trap
nearly causing a 15 car pileup and also
calling attention to the fact that they
were just speeding
okay the cops aren't dumb they're gonna
see that dozens of other examples
but here are the three main terrorists
of the roadways that deserve
specific and special condemnation
number one drivers who don't know how to
merge properly
i've always said that merging should be
on the driver's exam maybe it is now i
don't know
when i went through it it wasn't instead
you practice making three-point turns
and doing a couple other things
and then the final test the final boss
of the driver's exam when i was
doing it was a parallel parking
parallel parking a skill that as
expected i excel at but
that most people can go their whole
lives avoiding if they really want to
merging on the other hand you can't
avoid if you do it wrong
as many people do you'll get someone
killed now
you'll notice an emerging situation as
you are merging onto the highway there
is most of the time
a sign that says yield and very often
there is a thing called a merge
lane this is this is an area for you to
drive on as you merge
but most people experience some kind of
selective blindness
and act as though the yield and merge
lane don't exist what they'll do is in
rarer cases just dart
right into traffic charging in as if the
other cars on the highway are made of
pixie dust so there's no real
no need to worry about collisions more
commonly though
drivers will treat the yield like a stop
sign
and the merge lane like it will collapse
into a sinkhole if they drive on it too
far
so they'll come to a screeching halt in
the merge lane
and wait for an opening in traffic and
then enter the highway
going about 14 miles an hour oftentimes
causing whole busloads of orphans and
puppies to veer around them
and go careening off the highway and
over a cliff it happens all the time
now it's like it's like they they take
that entrance ramp and as soon as they
see the highway they panic
and they just stop still and they start
shouting what do i do what do i do
help help what do i do you drive is what
you do
okay what you're supposed to do is
continue driving along the merge lane
speeding up to match the speed of
traffic
yielding to oncoming traffic and
entering the highway as soon as space
opens up and allows it
it's very simple you go with the speed
of traffic number two parking lots
many drivers will cause unneeded
congestion and chaos in our nation's
parking lots by insisting on driving
around until they find a spot that's as
close as possible to the entrance of
whatever walmart they're trying to
access um these are the kinds of people
who
when you're you know when you're in a
spot and you're getting back to your
spot with your groceries they'll be
sitting there with their blinker on
impatiently waiting for you to pull away
putting undue pressure on you to unload
your groceries and buckle your kids up
and leave meanwhile there's a spot
literally 14 feet away that's open
and available they would rather wait for
14 minutes
in order to save themselves the 14 feet
this is the incorrect strategy the
correct thing to do is
is when you're in a parking lot pull
into the first
open spot you see no matter how far it
is from the building
when i when we go to football games in
the city for example as a family back
when that was still legal
i'll just take the first spot i find as
soon as we get into the city even if
it's 27 blocks from the stadium by the
time we walk there it's halfway through
the third quarter
but you know what i am not contributing
to parking lot congestion
unlike the rest of you heathens three
finally
this is a big one stop signs most people
know i hope that at a four-way stop
whatever car arrives first has the
right-of-way
if two cars arrive at the same time then
the car to the right has the
right-of-way these are the rules
the problem happens when there's
confusion or uncertainty about who
arrived first
and at this point in most four-way stop
situations everyone is frozen in panic
and fear nobody knows what to do someone
in one of the cars must lead must take
charge of the situation now me being the
only good driver i of course always
assume this leadership role
i say to the other drivers do not fear
do not be afraid
for i am with you i will show you the
way and at this point i will
magnanimously wave the other driver on
i'll just like this with generosity and
kindness in my eyes i will say go
go my child be free go but then what
always happens
the other driver will start waving to me
and they'll say oh no i couldn't i
couldn't accept this gift
you go you go my liege please i beg of
you so i say okay i accept your terms
and i start to go but then right at the
moment that the other right at that
moment when i'm going the other car says
never mind i think i want to go and they
start going and then i stop and say
okay then you go and they say no no
seriously you go never mind and i say
fine i'm going and right as i start to
drive they say actually i think i kind
of like to go
and they start driving and this game of
stop and start goes on sometimes for
hours
days this could all be avoided if you
would just
go from the first moment i wave you on
this is the rule of good driving if you
get waved on
just go just go you got the wave
go go you idiot i don't care if i'm
waving you into a volcano
you get the wave you go never defy the
wave
the very order and stability of our
society depends
on the power of the wave when you're
driving so go
and don't forget to give the thank you
wave in return you ungrateful bastard
most people struggle with most of these
points everyone but me struggles with at
least some of them
you might argue that i clearly do
struggle with immense amounts of road
rage and am not psychologically fit to
be driving the streets or indeed to be
in human society at all
that may or may not be the case but this
isn't about me
stop changing the subject this is about
you
and you as a driver are canceled
so if you're driving right now while
you're listening to this just pull over
get out of your car
leave the car there walk home that's
your only choice
all right um good glad we could
establish all that
that was very loud when i when i did
that okay uh
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico and our audio is
mixed by robin fenderson
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton
you